this has me excited these old yearbooks  oh look at this  look there's like a note it's love  letters dear Jimmy I don't know before I  leave there are several things I want to  tell you oh my God but the first thing  is naturally the most important and that  is this I'm gonna call you Friday night  I'm not too sure of the time but it will  be sometime between six and eight if you  really care enough you'll stay home  promise to try and make it please please  stay home until at least eight o'clock  if you're not home then I'll know you  don't care enough and we can end it  between us wow you hate to see it this  is a real love look a real letter May  2nd 1962.  this is some good stuff